Android libraries are essentially
fully featured Android apps
with the one restriction that they
can't be installed by themselves.
They have to be packaged into another
app to be installed on a device.
Android apps tend to consist of a whole
lot of files, so while you can totally
create an Android library by hand,
it's a lot easier to use the wizard.
Let's check out how to do that.
If you right-click on
the root of your project and
select New Module > Phone and
Tablet Applications > Android Library,
you can give your library a name and
an sdk, and then just like a normal app,
you can choose what kinds of
activities you want to add.
Let's add a blank
activity with a fragment.
We'll give it a name.
Now, a myLibrary folder has been
added to the root of your project
with all the familiar source and res and
even a manifest that you'd associate
with a normal Android app.
Also, the wizard is nice enough to add
your new library as a sub-project in
the multi-project build.
So, the last thing you need to do to be
able to use your new activity in your
base app is to head over to the
build.gradle file in the app directory.
And then we'll need to add
a compile time dependency
on the project myLibrary.
That's all there is to it.
Let's check out a working example.
So here's the demo from the course code,
which I strong suggest you go check out.
We've added this imageactivity
Android library to our project.
This library defines an activity with
its own layouts and with its own values,
like strings.
So here's the message that
the activity's going to display.
And this drawable of the Gradle logo
is also wrapped up inside our Android
library.
In settings.gradle,
imageactivity is added as a subproject,
and in the build.gradle
file of the app directory,
we have a compile time dependency
on the image activity project.
So that means in the main activity
of our main Android project,
we can import image activity and
set up an Intent to go launch it.
If we go ahead and
deploy that to our test device, here's
the activity from our app module and
our button which then launches
the activity from our Android library.
There we go.
We've made an activity that's easy
to reuse between applications.